there is something maddening about a
repetitive consistent sound don't you
agree the narrator of edgar allan poes
the telltale heart is driven mad by the
non-stop beating of a heart coming from
beneath his floorboards but even
something less horrible than a
disembodied heartbeat can fray a
person's nerves superficially less
horrible anyway something as simple as
say the relentless ticking of a clock
after all what could be more frightening
than a reminder of the sands of time
passing through our fingers of the
finite steps on life's long and winding
road we have the answer to that question
the scariest thing of all is the monster
waiting on the other side of the road
twisted and hungry the thing that
strikes when the ticking eventually
stops when time
is up tick tock tick tock
many years ago a clock maker in the
german town of freiburg was renowned for
his ability to produce exquisite
personalized clocks for his clientele
all across town the country and even
beyond his unparalleled constructions
made him the only man to reach out to
when it came to getting your hands on a
beautiful ornate timepiece that would
ease the anxieties of the passing hours
he ate slept and breathed clocks it was
his life his calling as such the
clockmaker had grown accustomed to the
sound of ticking he heard it in the
morning when he awoke to the cry of his
cuckoo clock he listened to it all day
in his workshop as he repaired and
constructed clocks of all shapes and
sizes and it was the sound that lulled
him to sleep at night after each long
hard day it gave life a pleasant rhythm
one day however he noticed a
particularly loud repetitive sound had
permeated his home it was rhythmic like
the ticking of his clocks but harsher
somehow it did not gently tick but
rather
cracked like the way his knees popped
when a harsh winter was coming something
in it made his stomach ache with dread
he began taking apart every clock in his
workshop looking for the source of the
sound but still
it persisted he sat there at his desk
surrounded by gears and pieces of wood
glass and metal and still the sound
pounded against his eardrums tick tock
tick tock the clockmaker was stumped by
the mysterious ticking noise it felt too
real too vivid to be some kind of
hallucination he would have bet every
clock he ever made that the noise was
coming from outside of his head he was a
man so astute in his clock-making
abilities that he could tell his own
creations apart in the dark from the
mere timber of their ticking but here he
was in the presence of an alien force
this frightening almost predatory sound
that lingered in his periphery always
somewhere but not confined to any fixed
point he was reminded vaguely of peter
pan of the crocodile that eaten captain
hook's hand and alarm clock which
survived and continued ticking in the
literal belly of the beast hook a
vicious pirate captain would become a
gibbering wreck when the ticking sound
got closer did he fear the predator whom
the ticking foretold or the passage of
time that pushed him further into the
reaper's fold in the otherwise immortal
plane of neverland tick tock tick tock
the clockmaker search continued he
turned his workplace upside down and
inside out in pursuit of the seemingly
sourceless ticking he checked every
hiding place every closet cupboard cubby
hole and cabinet nothing he moved the
furniture tied up the curtains rolled up
all the carpets nothing in his
desperation he took a claw hammer from
his toolbox and began prying the rusty
nails from the ground before peeling up
the floorboards and checking the dusty
spider-infested spaces underneath
perhaps some mechanism had fallen down
there or had always been there just
ticking away there had to be something
down there but no
only dirt insects and shadows maybe he
was going mad maybe it was tinnitus or
the indelible impression that hearing
years upon years of ticking had left in
his mind the way an image is burned into
a plasma screen if it's left there for
too long maybe it was some shadowy
government agency trying to drive him
mad with the use of some new sound-based
torture device oral terrorism selective
auditory subliminal mind control havana
syndrome the fizzling edges of sanity
egged on by the invisible long-range cia
telesound beams there had to be some
kind of explanation but whatever the
case the sound persisted tick tock tick
tock he couldn't stay there in the
dismembered ruins of his prestigious
clock making shop any longer he was
clearly under a lot of stress here not
healthy not good for the mind he decided
to close the shop for a few days and go
visit his daughter and her family some
time with his beloved relatives would
soothe his frayed nerves so he packed
his bag and made the trip hoping that
leaving work behind for a few days would
also loosen up his mind but the entire
drive to his daughter's house he could
have sworn he still heard the sound
keeping perfect time as it cracked again
and again he shook his head scolding
himself for imagining things there was
nothing in the car that could be making
that noise he'd focused on it too much
surely that's why he was obsessing over
it now all this had a rational
explanation he simply thought himself
he'd simply thought himself into a
corner on this one wouldn't that explain
all of this all just a trick in the mind
of an overworked clockmaker sorely in
need of a good sabbatical in the country
this wouldn't be forever tick
talk
tick talk the clockmaker's daughter
greeted him at the door with a warm
embrace and a hearty meal and for a
little while he relaxed the sound of
good company and laughter drowned out
the infernal ticking he began to
entertain the notion that perhaps the
ticking had been a good thing it had
been a long time since he'd seen his
daughter and that ticking as frightening
as it had been was also the only thing
that pushed him away from the workshop
for a while he was somewhat grateful for
a good excuse to take time off perhaps
that was what it was all about a
reminder to take it easy after a weekend
off he'd be right as rain surely but
that night as he tried to fall asleep
the sound was there
again
taunting him keeping his eyes open wide
and his heart rate climbing was it the
dark of the room magnifying his hearing
intensifying that awful ticking or was
it louder and closer than ever before it
felt as though an invisible clock like
so many he'd made before was hanging
over him but what was holding it that
awful awful sound like the bubbles
popping in the synovial fluids of a
person's aged and crumbling joints too
organic too fleshy and it just kept
getting louder and closer louder and
closer
louder and closer
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
tick tock tick tock
until suddenly it went silent he
breathed a sigh of relief and closed his
eyes the clockmaker's daughter woke to
the sound of her father's piercing
guttural screams she ran into his room
to find the bed she'd soaked with blood
the bedroom window shattered and her
father gone without a trace she went to
the police the next day but they could
do nothing for her her father had not
been the victim of an ordinary murderer
or thief but something outside the realm
of understanding it was something
ancient something mysterious something
monstrous
something
anomalous though the police could do
nothing
another organization was secretly on the
case the scp foundation after the
clockmaker's disappearance operatives
searched the area and discovered the
culprit which they captured and
designated scp-4975
scp-4975 is a humanoid entity with
bird-like features the most notable of
which is a sharp pointed beak its body
is long and thin with bony limbs with
tapered points
with no discernible digits of any kind
its body including its beak is covered
with a thick hard layer of skin the
entity's most notable feature is not its
appearance however but in its skeleton
particularly its spine the cervical
vertebrae of the creature are not
interconnected and are capable of
independent movement they rotate one
vertebra at a time from back to front in
order all the way up to the entity's
head in a particular rhythm this
produces the clicking or cracking sound
that is so terribly familiar to its
intended victims it repeats the motion
constantly over and over again only
stopping when it's preparing to attack
its chosen prey
scp-4975 does not kill impulsively
simply selecting a convenient victim
instead it stalks its prey for months at
a time sometimes even a year following
them in darkness hiding just out of
sight the only sign of its presence is
that sound the clicking cracking tick
tock tick tock of its bones as it bides
its time knowing that it can wait as
long as it needs or wants to before it
strikes when it's ready to feast it will
beat and tear at the victim's body with
the tapered points of its limbs
shredding the flesh and pecking at it
much like a vulture rips at a fresh
carcass then it can savor its meal using
the body as food for about three months
before it needs to hunt again though its
exact age is unknown it is theorized
that the creature is hundreds if not
thousands of years old written evidence
of its existence has been traced back as
far as the 1500s there are mentions of a
creature resembling
scp-4975 throughout german folklore
appearing in carvings paintings
folktales and nursery rhymes one such
nursery rhyme was discovered and
translated by the foundation during the
research process though its rhyme scheme
was lost when it was translated to
english the eerie feeling it evokes was
not the rhyme goes tick tock the cuckoo
clock ticks cuckoo the bird inside sings
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
as it ticks the time so ticks your heart
may you live long as you hear its song
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
listen close for when it stops the
hatchling comes out of its home tick
tock tick tock tick tock tick did you
hear it did it stop my child it meant
your time was up the research team
theorized that this nursery rhyme and
others like it was used to warn children
about potential indicators of danger
from scp-4975
and teach them to be wary of its hunting
patterns knowledge after all is one of
the best weapons in anyone's arsenal
when it comes to the anomalous without
much more knowledge than this little
poem provides and what they had observed
prior to
scp-4975's capture the scp foundation
did its best to create adequate
containment measures for the creature
currently
scp-4975 is kept in a standard steel
containment cell and is prohibited from
any direct human contact it can be
observed via security footage but no
human beings are permitted to go inside
lest they serve as the creature's next
meal if a containment breach occurs any
personnel that report hearing a
repetitive cracking or ticking sound are
to be isolated until the entity has been
captured and placed back in its cell or
until the sound stops though scp-4975
is currently contained there is a chance
that its captive state does not actually
make it any less lethal after a
harrowing incident that sent many
attending researchers to the on-site
psychologist's office the foundation was
given reason to believe that containing
it does not actually stop it from
hunting on september 16 2002 something
horrible happened near the black forest
in germany a team of foundation
operatives had been placed in the area
to monitor a man from fryeburg who had
complained to the local police about a
clicking sound that had been following
him around for quite some time over the
course of four months of being unable to
escape the sound or the feeling that he
was being watched no matter where he
went he had become convinced that
someone was stalking him it was a
bizarre situation and he wasn't certain
how his stalker was making this
maddening sound but he believed his life
to be in danger concerned that this
could be the work of scp-4975
the foundation operatives took him into
custody the police were given a cover
story claiming that the man was
experiencing a sense of paranoia as well
as auditory hallucinations as a result
of side effects from chemotherapy once
the foundation operatives explained to
the man that they meant him no harm
believed him about his fears and wished
to help he opened up about his
experiences he told the operatives that
in addition to the sound and the feeling
of something following him he had seen a
monstrous figure in the woods he had
kept the details to himself when
speaking to the police afraid they would
have him committed rather than listening
to him the operatives asked him to lead
them to the place where he had seen the
monster and he agreed the man led the
team to a densely wooded part of the
forest trees blocking out the sunlight
until their surroundings became as dark
as if it were the middle of the night as
they walked deeper and deeper into the
forest the man became increasingly
anxious his breath came in short
strained gasps his eyes started from
tree to tree and he jumped at the
slightest sound of a twig snapping
beneath someone's foot or branches
rustling in the gust of wind suddenly
mid-stride he froze his eyes were wide
his face was white as a sheet with a
trembling hand he pointed toward a
nearby tree in a voice so faint it was
almost a whisper he said
the operatives turned to look but saw
nothing there the man repeated
but they couldn't see anything but the
trees the man stumbled back going weak
at the knees from pure terror and
continued to point at the empty space
next to the tree just as one operative
was turning to another to comment that
their witness must be out of his mind
the man suddenly collapsed onto the
ground as if an invisible powerful force
had thrown him down the man screamed for
help struggling against the unseen
attacker as it slashed at his face in
this chest tearing through fabric and
skin blood spraying across the forest
floor two officers drew their weapons
firing at where they guessed the
assailant might be but their bullets
ricocheted uselessly off nearby tree
trunks another rushed to the man on the
ground grabbing him under the arms and
attempting to pull him out of harm's way
however the man would not budge as the
invisible force held him in place
shredding through his stomach as it
fought to keep its prey afraid to rip
open the stomach wound any further the
operatives quickly ceased his attempts
to move the man instead he pulled out
his weapon and did the only merciful
thing he could think to do he shot the
local man in the head putting him out of
his misery before he was ripped to
shreds the operatives watched some in
silent shock some continuing to fire
their weapons some vomiting from sheer
disgust as strips of the dead man's
flesh ripped off of bone and disappeared
one piece at a time meanwhile thousands
of miles away surveillance footage of
scp-4975's containment site picked up
some peculiar activity in the creature's
cell it stopped rotating its neck which
it had done almost constantly since
being captured and stared at the corner
of its containment cell its eyes were
wide unblinking and it did not move a
muscle it stayed still for several
minutes until it eventually broke the
unsettling stillness to eat greedily
gobbling down slices of meat there was
one problem though the creature had not
yet been fed that day all foundation
operatives dispatched to germany to
investigate
scp-4975 were recalled back to their
original sites and additional research
has been suspended until further notice
in light of this new information a
motion has been filed to reclassify the
creature as ketter and potentially
impossible to contain with the
foundation's current resources as
terrible as it is to admit this is one
monster the foundation has not yet found
a way to stop they may have it locked in
a cage but it can still hunt anyone
anywhere anytime it wants to wait a
second
be very very quiet what's that sound in
your room right now listen closely
tick tick do you hear it don't worry
it's probably just a clock or a kitchen
timer maybe it's just your imagination
tick tick tick whatever it is i'm sure
you'll be fine
there's nothing dangerous about a weird
sound from time to time you don't have
anything to fear unless it suddenly goes
silent that's when you're really in
trouble when you know
scp-4975 is about to strike to devour
you alive wait stop hold your breath
don't make a single beep do you hear it
neither do i
now go check out
scp-2316 the bodies in the water and
scp-966 sleep killer for more haunting
anomalies from the scp foundation